this is a production of Cornell
University
um yeah so as Louise said my name is
Kirsten Workman I am currently the
senior a senior extension associate with
Pro Dairy which is an extension program
at Cornell in the Cals um College of Ag
and life sciences and we're actually
housed at the animal science department
I am a certified crop advisor and I have
my Master's in Agronomy so I'm sort of
like an agronomist interloping in the
anal science department which is kind of
fun but I will try to recruit some of
you that way so it's okay
um just a raise of hands here students
in the room
awesome
and uh other people who have extension
appointments or do extension work I
recognize some faces awesome great fact
other just plain up plain old faculty
okay great
um super informal right my audience is
usually farmers and they're service
providers so feel free to like you know
Heckle me raise your hand yell out
whatever and stop me I will try to leave
about 10 minutes for questions so I was
telling Louie usually I cram like two
slides per minute I was good and only
put in like 30 something today so
um just a little bit about myself so
um just some context for pro Dairy and
I'll get into a little bit to how
extension works here at Cornell but we
have Cornell Cooperative Extension which
I'm sure you all have heard about which
operates just a little bit differently
than um people who have extension
appointments on the University so I'm
one of those campus-based extension
professionals
um but the pro Dairy program was started
over 30 years ago and was fun is is and
was funded through New York State mostly
the Department of Agriculture and really
the goal of pro Dairy was to enhance New
York's dairy industry through education
and applied research which is really the
mission of extension in the land grant
University
so our goal is to sort of facilitate
Economic Development by increasing
competitiveness and sustainability of
our dairy farms and here in New York
state of which there are many
um I came from Vermont just before this
where we're down below 500 and we have
almost 4 000 dairy farms here in New
York state so big difference there but
we kind of cover the whole farm so we
have folks like myself who are extension
Specialists that cover every area of the
farm from forage systems my area of
nutrient management environmental
sustainability we have a herd health
specialist we have a whole team of
Engineers looking at environmental
systems manure storages and energy
production and other facilities Farm
business management we have a small cost
share program we help fund environmental
and business best practices and we
actually also have a youth program
director so anything related to the
dairy farm we try to we try to cover I
also the original model of pro Dairy is
that extension Associates like myself
were paired with faculty members on
campus
um that doesn't exactly happen anymore
we could have a conversation about that
later maybe about how fewer and few of
our faculty have extension appointments
and as those folks have retired or moved
on they don't always get replaced and so
I think I might be one of a couple of
our senior extension and Associates in
proderi that still has that connection
with a faculty member so I'm part of the
nutrient management spear program I'm Dr
Corinne Kettering so I'm sure you guys
are all aware of
um and we partner together in that
program's mission and goals is quite
aligned with mine and Corrine Dr
ketterings has a very substantial
extension appointment so that matches up
so she does a lot of the applied
research I dabble my role is to get her
research out into the hands of farmers
and their service providers as Louis
said I'm old I now have to put 20 plus
years of experience which makes you
pronounce legit but also makes me sound
that's okay and I'll go into my career
and all that as we go so
um I do like to sort of describe myself
as an optimist and a pragmatist I think
anyone that works in how agriculture
sort of has to have both of those
qualities
um and so I sort of operate under
um those auspices so I will whenever I'm
in front of students I like to talk a
little bit about my career path not that
it's fancy or exciting but I think it's
helpful to hear how other people get
where they are so I currently have a
role of like a state specialist
essentially for extension which I still
sort of like don't quite buy into yet
but that's okay
um but clearly I didn't start there
right so I actually got my undergraduate
degree at a small liberal arts school in
Washington state called Pacific Lutheran
University my major was Environmental
Studies
kind of housed in the geology department
but it was a very broad it was a master
of arts so broad you know everything
from economics and ethics to science and
um and above so um out of college pretty
much
um I got a job with a Soil and Water
Conservation District
um in the Olympic Peninsula part of
Washington state
um in Mason County and worked there for
several years and it actually took a
little bit of a detour and I worked for
the Nisqually Indian tribes natural
resource department you might think like
what but in Washington state our Native
American tribes are actually by law
co-managers of all the natural resources
um and in the Puget Sound you can
imagine that's relies heavily on
Fisheries particularly salmon and
shellfish and so they have a robust
natural resource department that helps
manage that resource and I was part of
that team doing kind of education
Outreach on environmental practices for
other landowners to protect water
quality for the resource of the fishery
but actually in between those two things
I was really there was this idea of our
Soil and Water Conservation District
partnering with our local extension
office which was very appealing to me
but as you can imagine having two
different organizations try to figure
that out took a little bit of time well
the minute I took this job they sort of
figured it out and so I quickly had to
say goodbye to my Nisqually friends and
I took this position as the small farms
water quality educator for Washington
State University extension and that was
a joint position between those two
organizations and what was really
interesting about that
and I love this model and would love to
see more of it is that I got to Leverage
The the best you know the advantages of
both those institutions and sort of work
around the challenges of both those
institutions so I did make sure I was in
both offices physically every week and
were but clearly the same Farmers I was
working with same geographic region so
that wasn't difficult but when I needed
low overhead for a grant proposal I
would go through the Conservation
District when I need a lot of resources
or information or research expertise I
would look to WSU so it was a really
great combination
um so that was about 10 years or so um
it's my home state
um I then got married had a couple kids
um I'll talk about some other little uh
bird walks we took
um but as a just a series of events we
ended up in Vermont where my husband's
from and I took a position as an
Agronomy Outreach professional for UVM
extension working in the Lake Champlain
Watershed
um I do want to say that while I was
there I took advantage of the resources
and benefits of that position and
um did some professional development so
that's when I got my certified crop
advisor
certification which I still have and I
also got my Master's Degree as an
employee while I was there and luckily
my research project aligned with my day
job and so
um except for taking classes and writing
my research actually got to be part of
my day job which was nice
and then I came here in January of 2022.
so
um I did say there was some bird walks
but while I was in what kind of the end
of the last five years of my time in
Washington my husband and I owned a farm
called Barnyard Gardens we also opened a
Retail Nursery location associated with
it and when we moved to Vermont it was
actually for my husband's job that he
accepted a new and emerging role at the
Vermont youth Conservation Corps where
he sort of developed and grew what was
called the farm at vycc and it was a
youth development project but they
um instead of going out and fixing
trails and building lean twos they took
that same model and grew food and
distributed it through a hospital system
called the healthcare share and we got
to live there and I got to
um
basically like have cows which was my
goal
that I will say that that really helped
with my career right before I got my
Master's Degree I used to joke that
farming was my Master's Degree because
it really gave me that applied knowledge
that I could um connect with my other
producers and Farmers I could understand
where they were coming from I understood
their economics I understood the work
ethic I understood the market pressures
I understood you know the weather like
all those things I was able to relate
with them with and even here in Vermont
right I was even able to do things like
custom Grayson heifers for some of the
Farms I worked for or go milk a herd of
dairy cows on the weekends or
um you know
use their manure in some of my research
projects so it was a good sort of
synergy for me as my own professional
development and I really really value
that applied experience
although it does make for a busy
schedule
okay so anyone here know what a land
grant University is what does that mean
some of you should know
yes
yeah you raised your hand
oh the Library University system was
established after the Civil War and it
was established to create a university
in every state of our nation in granted
land yeah it's become controversial
um but it's an amazing model because it
allowed
the general person to getting access to
education higher education
um and in the areas of Agriculture and
economics and things that were really
important to the development of our
country what is your name by the way oh
my name is Allison and my ancestor who
is Justin Moore which you know is from
Vermont right
okay exactly you answered the question
perfectly right so the US government the
way they funded the formation of a
university in every state were these
sort of like grants of land but you kind
of had to figure out where they were so
I think there was that's where we get to
like well whose land was it and whose
was it to give away
um so in New York actually does anyone
know where our original land grant was
in Northern with in the northern
Pinelands of Wisconsin and so Ezra
Cornell was able to get it so our land
grant allotment for New York was 990 000
Acres
um and they sort of divvied it up by
population of course in the 18 whatever
we were at 64 or something I have the
dates on my notes so I'll pull it up
maybe if you guys want to see it or I'll
share them I have actual data in there
about the dates but
um essentially right we had 990 000
acres for New York allotted for
reference Vermont had like 30 000 Acres
so
um pretty sparsely populated it was sort
of relative right how many people do you
have to serve as a recording in my
research which was really interesting of
course Ezra Cornell right
um didn't do the quick and easy thing
and just sell because the idea was you
would sell this land you would gain the
income from the sale and you would use
that to start your University as it was
a much better businessman than that and
so he was able to convince the people
putting together this University with
him to wait until the land was worth
more and they could maximize that profit
and I think it was something upwards of
five million dollars at the time was
there's a lot of money but they had to
wait to realize the return on that
investment and so I think things were a
little tight there for a little bit and
the University was really founded with
an endowment from Ezra and then when he
passed away before it all sort of came
to fruition the folks who sort of helped
him through this land grant purchase
maintained that goal of his to wait
until it was really worth a lot of money
and I don't know if any of you recognize
this if you ever park near Morrison Hall
right the land grant Mission really
aligned with Ezra Cornell's mission
where the idea that any person could
come and access education on any topic
so what about extension
what is extension it's a hard
question you want to take a stab at it
got some extension people here
the primary wing of translational
research by research basically the
questions are supposed to be coming from
the stakeholders and they were supposed
to be applying any scientific nothing
right so it's supposed to be based in
the local community to say what are the
questions and challenges that we had
ahead of us and looking to us as the
land grant University to help them
answer that right so clearly the idea is
that it's coming from the community up
and then we're going back not sort of
from top down right but it sort of
happened both ways I would say
responsibility to see what's coming
right exactly so us as extension folks
right we're supposed to be know what's
coming and anticipate that and help
producers stay ahead of the game that's
really how it has worked over time in
the Northeast basically like 19 in the
early 1900s
um
we were figuring this out and many
counties and States sort of created
their extension systems just ahead of
the actual you know legislation and law
that made it formal probably a year or
two before
um and that was around you know 1912 to
1906 sort of that range and then in 1913
we had a Smith lever act it sort of
solidifies extension and gives some sort
of funding mechanism which we now call
formula funds in the form of the Smith
lever act and again based on your you
know where you are in the country and
your population all that stuff is the
formula and every state and university
has to match those formula funds and
here in Cornell's we have a unique
system where us as extension folks can
then compete and apply for that funds in
some states they just sort of decide
where it goes and it should have an
extension component right
um and but really the the Focus here
this is from Sullivan County I think
um but the point was that this was
supposed to be community-led so these
extension associations were actually
boards and groups of local farmers and
townspeople that would come up with a
list of topics they wanted education on
and as you can imagine in the early
1900s a lot of that was on home
economics and agricultural techniques
and that has very much evolved over time
and now because it's very locally LED
you could go to any extension office in
New York right and find a different sort
of priority or Focus based on that
community so if you're somewhere where
there's a lot of Dairy Farmers you might
have a very robust sort of Dairy Field
crops program if you're in New York City
right we don't really cover that there
um but you might have a lot of urban
programs and Youth Development so just
depending on the needs of the community
um they and then they are sort of still
in New York the original model is sort
of these like subordinate government
entities and so the way they are funded
often is variable but there's usually
some connection to the county some
connection to USDA and then they often
have to do some fundraising so here in
New York Cornell Cooperative Extension
sometimes there's some University
funding towards staff there's County
funding towards staff and then they'll
write a lot of Grants and you know sort
of creative ways to fundraise in order
to fund their programs and their people
um in some states like where I came
before in Vermont we were just
University employees so I did not rely
on a County government to fund me every
year so and Washington sort of was like
waffling between the two as I left so it
definitely changes and can be
exciting challenging
um it just depends on where you're at
so that idea of Applied research and
education is really core right to the
value and mission of extension and
really being in the local communities
working alongside those Farms to help
them come up with Solutions and and
those change over time right
any questions about
extension my goal is to recruit you all
as students as extension employees
eventually there's lots of opportunities
across the country and you know I will
say that the United States right is
unique that we're really the only
country that has this system so well
supported and implemented and in every
state right in our country it exists in
some way shape or form
and other countries really
look to it as an example and pull people
from our pool to help build and develop
similar programs in other countries
the why is this land grant Mission and
extension important clearly unbiased
right but one of my former colleagues at
UVM who is a vegetable specialist I
think put it really good you know it's
this idea of marrying technology but
really the idea of Social Capital
becomes really important in our work
because if we don't have the trust of
farmers right are they going to take our
advice and if we don't listen to them
and solve their problems do they care
about our work and if my budget you know
depends on the County government which
is often made up of those same people
who sit on Town boards and County uh
Commissioners and things like that it it
wouldn't pan out so you you know that's
really key and it really is this
community of learning and I know that
Vern and you know my colleagues here in
New York agree that we learn as much
right from our work with farmers and our
relationships with Farmers as they're
really learning from us
and it is pretty magical
so right what does it look like now kind
of the same right same ideas same
tenants same Concepts
um but different right AG is farming is
different it's different than it was 100
years ago 150 years ago it's different
than it was 20 years ago and it's going
to be different in five years right so
the key for extension and the land grant
mission is to be anticipating and to be
always looking forward and to evolve
with
um with whether it's agriculture or
natural resources or Youth Development
right we don't an extension only do AG
I'm going to focus on that but
um so we have to evolve along with it I
think one of the biggest things in the
last 10 years really and Louis clearly
his position is evidence of that is that
technology information data right
Precision agriculture has really changed
how we think about farming and how we
interface with farmers and their data so
that's something we're all learning
um and the issues have changed right but
in the end it's really about people so
this is one of my CCE Regional extension
Educators Jody she works in Western New
York right like I can't be everywhere
um this is one of our bigger projects so
um Jody is the local Extension agent and
we rely on her to like give us a heads
up if it looks like the farmer's going
to plant corn and he hasn't called us
yet or you know if she's out there and
notices they haven't done a very good
job of weed control or we just need her
to help us sample that day because it's
got to happen so we can get out of the
field for the farmer to go about his way
so those relationships are really
important and again right they can
provide us information about if we're
headed in the right direction because
they are the boots on ground locally too
yeah
so just some basic tenets here right
like what's been key in my career and
made me I think successful
um is really meeting Farmers where
they're at and saying like where are you
whether it's farming system land-based
education technology scale whatever it
is and understand what the barriers are
to them solving whatever problem and
trying to remove those barriers that's
kind of what I really see is the role of
extension and that takes the form and
you know takes a lot of forms
um so we think a lot about this applied
research and education but there's
definitely a way to go about that so
those of you that have been to our
research Farm facilities right that's
one way to do research frankly I've done
very little of that research almost all
of my research has been on farms
and the reason is
as silly as it sometimes sounds there
might be farmers in one County and
farmers in another County and they might
feel like whatever's happening over here
doesn't apply to that and so to do it in
all the places where those farmers are
becomes an important piece and to listen
to them about what they want to know and
hear and see
um right so I kept hearing like yeah
yeah plots like that's great they want
to see the data they always want to see
the data
um but if you're going to try and
demonstrate or show something they want
it bigger I always wanted
um and they want it close by right so
that's where extension comes in and so
we go from smaller plots to bigger plots
um you know we were having good soil
Health conversations this was 10 years
ago or more
um and there's very different soils
depending on where you are right and
different Landscapes and so to dig a
soil pit on one farm and do a soil
Health display the results are
completely different than when you go
like two miles over in a different
totally different soil type
um you know the way we look at cover
crops and demonstration plots and you
know do I do this with real life farm
equipment that is of the scale the
farmers are going to use whether it's
big enough or also small enough right is
important
and then right so this is just one
example I was just excited because two
of my research projects showed up on
Google Maps once I was like ooh
screenshot
um this was my Master's project and this
was a cig project we had on cover crops
right so these were these were small
plots for my Farmers they were about 100
feet long and then this is the whole
length of a field right where we were
showing off different sort of
combinations of cover crops in a field
Farmers field
um it's all the way up to really what
they want to know is what's it looked
like on a whole field or half a field
split or something like that right and
now I think with yield monitors and
precision data now
um doctor a lot of doctor and
kettering's work currently is looking at
how do we use that yield data so that
farmers can do their own research and
have it not just be like this isn't
replicated plots I couldn't use this for
statistics but I'll tell you what it
sure changed a lot of farmers Minds
right we can take the Best of Both
Worlds and actually get statistically
valid data out of these when we have a
million little yield data points from an
entire field
we do it right
the other role I feel of like for
extension is like I feel like it's my
job to mess up first
it's my job to figure it out with the
farmer but I want to mess up on my dime
before I'm like yeah you should do this
how many how many people have heard
stories are like well 20 years ago
extension told us to do this and now
you're telling me to do that right so we
want to make those mistakes and figure
out all the Kinks alongside the farmers
but in a way where we're kind of taking
on the risk and whether that's through
equipment or application of practices or
you know funding strategies whatever
that looks like
um right so as we were figuring out
cover crops right we wanted to figure
out the pitfalls before we were saying
yes this is how you do it
what I'll tell you you find is you need
lots of different approaches right I
always talk about we need the big
toolbox with lots of tools in it and
then you'll know which situation is
right for which tool hopefully but
you'll learn so this is just a couple
examples right we have the winter radish
cover crop and a winter Rye cover crop
both were dead but clearly some
differences here right come June when
the corn is growing similarly right we
made a mistake here
and we didn't get the cover crop killed
oh we figured that part out and now
right so we go from the farm saying that
doesn't work
just saying well what did we do wrong
and then we fix it and then we can
figure it out right and these are the
this plot is this one here next the one
where we clearly didn't do the right
thing so
figuring those out along the way and
sort of documenting the good bad and the
Uglies is also really important
so just figuring it out right this is
just an example is working with a lot of
farms on reduced tillage and in this
case the farm called me I think on a
Friday no a Thursday and said hey we've
got eight acres of corn left we want to
try this no-till thing
we have eight acres worth of seed I've
got a small hay field I'm willing to
give up
um can you get me six different sets of
closing wheels so I can test them out
well I said sure Mark when are you
planting um tomorrow at noon okay am I
calling every farmer I know are you done
corn planting because I'm going to take
two of your closing Wheels
um so that's what we did right and they
planted and we flagged each little set
of rows and we came back and we did
population counts and right did we
change the world no but did that farmer
keep trying no-till and asking questions
yeah so you know it's like okay that's
important and even when I collect data
that's not statistically valid right I'm
still able to share it with producers
and say you know what it didn't really
matter which wheel we use because they
all closed the trench so we did a good
job kind of thing
um versus the one right that didn't and
we did see a difference on this Farm
so here's another thing about sort of
adoption and Technology transfer we had
a small Grant where we had two of these
10 foot no-till drills that we took all
around the Champlain Valley to try and
encourage cover crop
um planting
um which worked pretty good because
they're 10 feet and they drive down the
road pretty easily but you put them in
an actual Big Field and the farmer who
looks at you like what that's gonna take
me forever to plant right so they try it
for a few times and then what do they do
right they bought a 30-foot drill right
and so these two little 10 foot hay
Busters that we drove around in our
little extension truck for a couple
years
um with some good coordination with our
agency partners who funded some
equipment purchases turned into in one
County in Vermont there's probably now
two dozen 30-foot no-till drills that
get used for planting cover crops every
year
um so was that worth a grant fund of you
know 250 000 bucks one year
probably yep and just knowing right like
and then what we were doing here
actually was planting some demonstration
plots while the farmer was planting like
the whole rest of the field in the same
amount of time
but what happens is you will see that if
you know starting small is important
taking incremental steps but you have to
be able to like adapt quickly because
that's what the farmers are going to do
let's say adapt technology
and just to show an example here in
Vermont
um when I started there in 2011 there's
um there's like a hundred thousand acres
of corn a little less and there was
maybe a hundred acres of cover crops
planted on that corn ground some
vegetable Growers were doing it
um but we s you know started working
with our nrcs partners our state agency
the water quality folks extension soil
water conservation districts kind of all
got around one issue and we were able to
start with like a small project with a
helicopter which I call charismatic
megapana
um and get 5 000 Acres done it was okay
but by the end of like this is 2018 and
now we're sort of above that we had a 35
adoption of cover crops on our annual
cropland like that's pretty significant
so my mom's a small state there's not as
many farmers it's a little easier to get
that kind of fast change but still you
know you once you get that momentum
right if you do your job well you can
see change happen really fast which is
frankly really rewarding
um and again right not just the one
practice but whole systems this was the
soil type I was working in
um very heavy clay
um so Wright has challenges
um but and people always said no-till
doesn't work and cover crops aren't
going to work right but very quickly our
Farms went from some just basic cover
crop applications to like doing all
sorts of cool stuff and I used to joke
that like I just would go around
following them and trying to take good
pictures right and share it and get
other Farmers to come look at it
um so like I said once once we've like
convinced them then they're like
optimizing it to fit their system which
is really exciting and then our job is
just to sort of tell the story and
convince them to tell the story right so
this is one farmer I worked with in the
Champlain Valley George Foster his son
actually is the crop manager for Duman
Farms one of the largest grain producers
in New York state
and he was just he was really quiet
dimir fella and he just became this
Champion he's come here to talk in New
York
um he's been to national no-till
conferences I think I have a picture of
him winning an award and you know he's
he's not like the guy you would have
picked out of the room to be your your
spokesperson but in the end he really
was and we made a law of Headway because
of farmers like George and his cohorts
and um and getting them in groups of
people to make big change so we had
three different farmer organizations
that were formed really address soil
health and water quality
there they are when these two guys not
very excited are they
he was excited that's his excited face
um so they were able you know we we
formed the Champlain Valley farmer
Coalition which really showed some
leadership and like I said was we could
not have done what we did there without
them and they were able to win this um
this award a national no-till conference
and George and
and Dave got to go for free so that was
pretty time it was this first time on
airplane actually
it's pretty cool
um and then the other piece for
extension right and I just came from a
meeting of people that were not Farmers
right but this is more and more a part
of our job is to be the the person that
interprets farming to the rest of the
public I mean we're below two percent of
our population that are farmers and
we're now it's been that way for long
enough that most people don't have any
context for farming and so really that's
our job right I mean it's the farmer's
job but really it's our job as extension
especially
um to be that person that's doing the
interpretation and in Translation to our
you know the public who don't have
context and I think in rural New York in
rural Vermont and other places you often
have people who
um have proximity to agriculture but
don't have context so they definitely
have an opinion but it may or may not be
based in fact right so I think about the
person who drives behind the manure tank
or on their way to work and it looks
dirty and smells bad and they have no
idea what's actually happening right or
they see mud in the road behind it and
think it's manure or like I get a lot of
my newer complaints
um but you know that idea then I can
then help explain herbicides and
pesticides man that's some of my
toughest conversations but gosh I'd
rather have that one than have a farmer
feel like they're being sort of vilified
right in front of their neighbors so if
I can help that a little bit like
having the tough conversations I feel
like is where I live a lot these days
and this is our state um and our CS
conservationist talking to one of our
farmers in Addison County
um about his manure injection methods
right he didn't have to let these people
on his farm
let alone all these other people this is
a student from Middlebury College not
um Gerard's very outgoing fella um and
uh the student from Middlebury College
um I was just sort of walking behind
them eavesdropping and she asked him
about why he wasn't an organic farmer
and so they're having that conversation
um right there and it was really awesome
right like she got to hear his
perspective he was respectful so she was
like oh my gosh
um perfect
so any questions about that I have some
other sort of Lessons Learned I'll get
to here in a little bit but I wanted to
touch a little bit anyone here deal
directly with sort of environmental
relation issues as they relate to
agriculture
yeah you guys can raise her you know you
raise your hand
okay well this is where I live as the
environmental sustainability specialist
my entire career
has at some level been dealing with
water quality as it relates to our
farming practices
um so why do we think extension right
needs to be sort of involved in this
arena in terms of farming I think it's
really important I think
um there's also this piece about
regulation and whether people with the
land grant University or extension
should be involved in shaping regulation
or not and then also like how do we
build incentive programs for adoption so
this I just showed this is from the tmdl
in Lake Champlain it's I don't think
it's the most recent version but you can
see here in the um the total Watershed
38 which is not the majority but it's
the largest source right of the runoff
into Lake Champlain from phosphorus was
coming from agriculture so clearly
something that needs to be addressed
right
um in Vermont it was up over 40 percent
and so that's a space right where we got
to be engaging because if we don't
engage where do our Farmers end up later
right if if environmental regulations
either get developed without them
um or don't take into account actual
farming practices right we could create
regulations that put all of our Farms
out of business or have unintended
consequences
um and so I spend a lot of my life also
here especially now in my role at
Cornell helping people who run the
concentrated animal feeding operation
permit and water quality rules and now
climate um change so those are all
important pieces I mentioned climate
change so we now have policies being
formed one the first ones here in New
York that will have some some role to
play and how we think about farming
right we have a pretty small piece of
the footprint but we also have a big
role to play in terms of solution and
we're early enough if we can do it well
we can maybe avoid some regulation
this soil Health piece while not
seemingly environmental really to me is
sort of where all the things come
together and the reason I pointed out
not just because my soil Health
colleagues are here but because this has
been the space where I've seen the most
sort of like eyes light up from Farmers
right so you can be addressing all sorts
of goals when you talk about soil Health
that can include production right but
also can include reducing your
environmental footprint and being more
profitable and a lot of different things
and farmers are producers right they get
excited about that so when I you know
I've never had a farmer text me a
picture of their nutrient management
plan getting finished right like Oh yay
my nutrient management plan showed up
right but they do send me pictures of
like hey this is my no-till cornfield
look at all those really cool or
handfuls of soil that look beautiful
right on a cornfield that's been under
really good management for 10 or 12
years and it's a place where we can
really sort of think about where it
comes into context with our community
and watersheds and air sheds and all of
the above
right
and unfortunately right when it comes to
the environment I mentioned like the
public has a role to play like without
the public pushing for good
environmental regulations right maybe we
would never have had the Clean Water Act
which I think we would argue we needed
the Clean Water actually
um but it can kind of Swing the other
way right so here we have a water
quality practice manure pits are one of
our number one ways to protect water
quality so we're not spreading manure in
the winter
um and we have neighbors who like don't
want them right and we'll we'll protest
send their kids up there right they'll
accuse The Soil and Water Conservation
District executive director of like
being in the pocket right and
gaining some sort of financial benefit
from this idea
um so it gets very emotional right and
so that's a position where you know we
sort of have to think about how do we
craft our message and how we bring
science to the conversation which is
becoming really difficult too so science
communication is big
and then we get into even worse things
right where farmers are getting sued so
I've had the lovely privilege of being a
witness on a lawsuit against a farmer
right where
um that puts you in a difficult position
um and now we have another one right so
in New York state we have
um a current lawsuit that's going
through litigation we're in the
discovery phase right now a farm that
frankly is in complete compliance with
their kfo permit but now they're paying
a lawyer tens of thousand dollars a
month to just defend what they're doing
and what we've been asking them to do
for 20 years through our permitting
process
um and so you know it's not going away
so a few lessons I think I've learned
along the way
I haven't already mentioned them right
this idea of expert this is Gerard again
um are you the expert or are you part of
a cohort right so are you the person
standing up um what's the uh one of my
colleagues that does social research for
extension said it's more of a guide by
your side versus Sage on the stage right
so instead of standing up talking about
what we should be doing in farming right
you should be with next to your farmer
helping them come up with Solutions and
helping them interpret information
that's what I feel like I do a lot of
too like yes we have some information
but what does it mean to you
um
right the other role I think that's been
really helpful in my careers I just
think of myself as a convener right so
there's people doing really cool stuff
my job is to make sure the right people
know about it right so we had a cool
project with a grassland manure injector
right you have a field day people get
excited they want to see equipment they
want to look at it right lots of good
conversations you get more adoption
people see things on the ground and that
could be a group like this it could also
be two farmers who were neighbors but
they never have enough time to like
check each other out or see what's going
on or just like feel uncomfortable
asking and I say oh do you mind if I
bring so and so over to take a look at
your corn planter sure whatever you know
and then those conversations start to
happen
the other piece right is is is really
the The Base mission of land grant
universities and extension is we we do
have to measure right we can't manage
anything without measuring it first and
Farmers know that right but they also
have a lot to do and so if I can make
that measurement part easier
um I think that's a good role to play
and then helping them make those
management decisions you know and I say
here the basics are still important here
we're calibrating a manure spreader and
here we're just leveling
um uh we're leveling the um the Ripper
right and that's just little things it's
just basic Agronomy it's not like new
and exciting science but it's a good
reminder that like oh right the basics
of agronomy are still really important
in how we Farm even with all this other
technology we have
it I'll tell you Farms always
overestimate how much manure they're
spreading people think they
underestimate but every time I calibrate
a manure spreader they were under
underestimating
I think the other piece that I've come
to realize that you know how do you feel
when someone shows you and shows
interest in your work and they say oh
tell me about what you're doing right
like oh that's cool someone cares about
one they thought it was kind of cool and
they wanted they want someone else to
hear about it and they want me to come
talk about it and you know I didn't do
this intentionally this way it's like a
social experiment but as I started doing
more and more of this and working with
groups like The Champlain Valley farmer
Coalition and we have been in New York
the partners for healthy watersheds like
when you go to like how many times is a
farm or a farmer have anyone interested
in what they're doing other than like
okay who needs the truck and what piece
of equipment but like someone from
outside their Farm to be like oh what
are you doing really that's so cool
right like it is
do you mind if you would you come talk
to some people about it that's like oh
okay I can get up in the morning every
day and do this thing and like someone
actually thinks it's kind of cool
um and I think that has gone a long way
frankly
there's my charismatic megafauna big
cool equipment it's like really exciting
people love it it's not always the right
solution but it gets people out to a
field day you can see the people
underneath that
hi Clarence we were spreading cover crop
seed in between tall very tall corn
plants with that machine
the helicopter was the same
so again this idea about the question
about whether or not to get involved in
regulations and policy and I've had some
um I don't want to say heated but robust
conversations with my extension
colleagues over the years about if this
is a role for extension or not
um and I'm not going to tell you there's
a right or wrong answer I will tell you
that I've been grateful when I have been
involved in those
um in those spaces mostly because if
we're going to have regulations that a
are implementable and B actually
accomplish the goals we're setting out
to do we have to involve the people
we're trying to regulate and it's really
hard to get Farmers to the that process
and so I see my role as getting Farmers
to the process for input but also to
bring data so that those decisions get
made in a way where it's based on actual
information and not just assumptions or
something that happens somewhere else
and this can be in a lot of ways this
happens in labor this happens in the
environmental space it happens
um you know Animal Welfare so you know
thinking about for me in my career if I
had not participated in some of these
policy and Regulatory
um processes that out not me personally
like I made some wonderful contribution
but knowing if we had not engaged in
that space as extension and conservation
districts and Farmers the outcome would
have been
um not as good mostly because I think
the farmers would not have received it
well
like you want me to do what but when
they're there at the table they're like
okay well it could have been worse right
or actually they were going to make us
do this or you know then they can tell
their neighbors like oh no actually this
is legit
and then again just being that mistake
maker Problem Solver
um you know not assuming you have all
the right answers and just you know
literally shoulder to shoulder elbow to
Elbow trying to work through stuff
together
and then the most important piece of our
of our work and extension really is the
people right the other people in
extension the people in the communities
your local government folks and of
course the local farmers that we're
working with and we just have to always
keep that in the front it's like this is
community this is people there's
um anyone that's ever worked in
extension is like wait a minute I have
all the scientific knowledge I need I
have all this but no one gave me a
counseling degree you know I've been at
tables where farms and families are in
tears like why was this year talk about
fertilizer
I didn't sign up for this
um right so it's very much a people
process not just a science data
information process and remembering that
that's important and what I found is
it's really important to convey that to
the other people in your community
because often the farm gets pointed at
and people forget that it's the farmer
right and he's a person and he might
have yanked your car out of the snow
bank last winter and he probably is on
your school board and you know he's on
the fire department or whatever so I try
to always keep that at the Forefront of
my conversations with people and the
best way I do that is I give Farmers to
show up and talk to those people
and just real quickly here some adoption
right just to show it does work right
we've learned that if you look at the
state um here the orange number is like
the whole state 30 adoption of tillage
and cover crop but when we focus on a
priority Watershed and like their needs
and issues what kind of adoption do we
get up gets up closer to 50 percent and
then if you start to look at your early
adopters and people who are really
really dedicated right it's more like 60
or 70 adoption rate over time
um so knowing how to Target your effort
and and kind of Leverage that kind of
change is important
um I already talked about sharing the
good news right there's a lot of good
news to share
um so being that person Farmers
inherently don't like to talk about
themselves
um or show off so I do that for them
um I'll just work through these right it
helps to have a big a big sticky issue
to work around and kind of bring
everyone together on I talked about
charismatic megafauna really getting to
yes I try to never say no
right it's like yes and yes but or yeah
we can do that but not right now we got
to figure out a way to get it done kind
of thing
um you know getting your hands dirty
being in it with um
um definitely there's no one-size-fits
all
um sticking to the basics
um and I truly do believe that if we can
keep things
voluntary when it comes to environmental
regulations we're going to be in a much
better place than if we try to regular
weight regulate our Farmers into it
because agriculture really culture is
the the active word there right and so
if we can get them to adopt uh ethos or
a mentality or a system they are going
to adopt it and optimize it if we tell
them they have to they're going to say
by when and how much and that's where
they'll stop right but if they decide to
do it and they see all the benefits and
all their neighbors are doing it not
because they were made to but because
they want to that's the place to go
clearly I love my job so I'm not going
to talk too long about that but it
really is a vocation not a career or an
occupation like this is you don't do it
for the money
um but you do it because you love
agriculture you love the people you work
with you love extension you love
continuing to learn right that's what I
love about my job
um and I also love that I get all the
fun parts of farming right but having
like mine
paycheck tied to it if I have a crop
loss like oh
I'll write an article about that
um
and because I have students here right
if you want to come over to animal
science and do some Agronomy over there
we have some options for you we do have
a whole Farm nutrient planning class
that we offer in the spring and animal
science 4120 green offers an independent
study to walk you through getting taking
the CCA exam and then we have several
opportunities for summer internships if
you're at all interested in sort of
dairy sustainability digital agriculture
extension
um and we even have some engineering and
if you're interested in what like crop
consultants and nutrient management
planners do we have lots of
opportunities with us at Pro Dairy and
um in the animal science department so
I have five minutes for questions
foreign
experience or
thoughts
it's a great career yes thank you very
much for visiting us and hopefully not
the last time yeah I hope not they did
Welcome
um belated welcome
um and uh yeah I agree with with
everything you said and especially how
you say it
um that makes me really excited about
learning more about your work I was
wondering uh
you mentioned the resources at the
University such as Cornell and there are
a lot of research teaching faculty
um what have you seen that works
to reach out to those faculty and rope
them in to what you're doing and what
you need to deliver what hasn't worked
yeah
and uh here at Cornell or elsewhere yeah
I think what doesn't work like from The
Faculty side of things
um I think what doesn't work is when the
faculty member says oh I have this
project
because of whatever it's got an
extension component and like the last
year the project they're like hey we got
to have a meeting about this like that
doesn't work
um and so I do think having like we can
proof things out in plots and small
scale but if we start to see some
benefit like how do we get that out on
the landscape and can we do some larger
things with farmers and I think the key
is to be if you can't be there right if
we're on campus and you can't be
everywhere all the time who are the
connections we need to make in that
Community with that type of farm who is
their trusted advisor so that picture of
Jody right like that's kind of key in
our work and we have extension Educators
across the state where we can key in
with those folks be partnering with them
provide them with resources through
funding or otherwise they're always
looking for money to like keep their job
whole
um and then they really are the ones
that like can tell you where you might
want to put that project what soil types
what Farmers the good cooperator where
if you just sort of be like oh that one
right we can fail miserably so I think
communication is the key and not just
swooping into a place like I try not to
swoop in if I'm going to go do a meeting
somewhere I try to like call the
extension agent like hey I'm going to be
in you know Wayne County are you going
to be there like do you want to help me
give this one presentation or you know
who which Farm should I come visit will
you come with me you know so knowing who
those trusted advisors are and having
really good communication and being
um you know again making sure we're
solving the farmer's problem not just
being an inconvenience to the farm
because once you're helping them solve a
problem then like watch out we have some
Farms that call us I'm sure you guys do
too you're like oh boy this is going to
take a while right and they call you all
the time it's awesome
thank you for a very clear
enjoyable presentation thank you I liked
it uh one of the things that you
mentioned was the role of looking ahead
what's coming and the Press right now is
filled up with information about the use
and misuse of artificial intelligence
does it have any role in research and
extension in agriculture that you see
yeah that's a really good question and
we had like a lunchtime conversation
with us animal science Master's student
what I was like I don't know about this
you know AI stuff and he was really
clearly like well you better get on the
bandwagon or you're going to get left
behind right and that was like a wake-up
call like yeah right so I think the idea
I think I think we need to figure that
out and figure out what it's like any
other tool in our toolbox what is going
to be where we apply it and where we see
benefit and where do we want to make
sure we don't because there could be
some consequences we don't want to see
happen
um I don't know the answer to those
questions for agriculture right now but
I think it is a good question and one
frankly we're probably not paying enough
attention to in agriculture so I don't
think like I think artificial
intelligence like in a slightly
different way about how we model and
predict and use that farm data but like
the way that AI is being used now is
like a completely different thing and I
think we can't ignore it even though I
kind of want to because it kind of
scares me
I have maybe one last question yep and
I'll just put my contact info up there
what have you seen over the last I mean
all your experience
uh is a good ways and how it evolved
good ways to communicate with the
farmers and like maybe your website may
not have been yeah three years back yeah
maybe it's not still that's a really
good question
um you know we think about all the
extension bulletins we create and the
Publications and the websites and the
videos
and as unsexy as it sounds being at
their door yard and talking to them in
person
that's still the way to go it's
expensive it's time consuming
um but I still think that's at the top
of the list I think there are still
although I will say cell phones are
amazing
texting
awesome and understanding which so some
Farms email bam they'll email you right
back
um they read every newsletter you send
right there's those farms and then
there's some Farms you can call
um they'll always pick up but if you
send them an email they might tell you
I've had Farmers tell me once I don't
check my email till January I was like
whoa okay
um you know it's getting a little better
on that front
um but I do think you need to identify
because I've done printed newsletters
digital newsletters email campaigns you
know blah blah blah and it really is
understanding whose communication like
you've got to meet them where they're at
and some Farms it's just you show up or
you call or you call their wife or you
call their daughter or their son or who
is the right person at the front like
and that you only get with like practice
and relationship building and time
um but I do think it's worth like
continuing an extension to like canvas
and ask what's the best way to get
communication to you like here we're in
New York right we have a lot of plain
sex people and you know clearly like I'm
not going to email them text them or
call them on their cell phone I have to
wait to be invited frankly as a female
to come and speak at one of their
meetings and I have to like have the
trust of one of their trusted advisors
to at all be heard right where Some
Farms like I said I can send them a
research paper and they've read it and I
just didn't have 10 questions for me by
the next day
um and some people just saw it on
Instagram or Facebook so
um I think having all the things out
there and I think science communication
and having professionals who are really
good at that to help us is super
important
great thank you very much Kirsten Gmail
if you're at all interested in
internships or whatever
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu